And the Midianites sold Joseph
into Egypt unto Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaohs
and captain of the guard.
And Joseph was brought
down to Egypt and Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaoh,
captain of the guard,
and Egyptian bought him of
the hands of the Ishmaelites,
which had brought him down.
Thither so now he's a slave.
So now you'd think,
well,
that would be,
this is a man who has a lot of reason
to be irritated at the structure of
reality,
right?
He's gone from being the favorite to
being betrayed by all of his brothers.
That's pretty rough.
And then he's being transformed
into a slave and now he's being,
he's being sold to work as a slave.
So you'd think that that would corrupt
his character because you know,
one of the things,
I think this is the case anyways,
I think people are always looking
for an excuse to have their character
corrupted.
Because if your character is corrupted,
then you get to lie and you get to cheat
and you get to steal and you get to be
trade and you get to act resentfully
and he get to do nothing.
And that's all easy.
It's easier to lie than to tell the truth.
It's easier to do nothing
than to do something.
So there's always part of you thinking,
well,
I need a justification for being
useless and horrible because that,
that'd be a lot less work.
And so then if something
terrible comes along,
you think,
Aha,
that's just exactly the
excuse that I was waiting for.
And then out all of outcomes,
you know,
a soldier Dimson when he was in
the concentration camps in Russia,
watching how people behaved,
you know,
he said that there were people that were
put into camps who immediately became
trustees,
are guards,
and they were even more vicious than
the people who had been hired as guards.
And his idea was that they
had collected all that,
he called it fallenness,
if I remember correctly,
around them in normal life.
But they didn't have the
opportunity to express it.
But as soon as you gave
them the opportunity,
it was like there,
it was right away.
And so,
yeah.
So one of the messages that seems to echo
through these old testament stories is
that just because something
terrible happens to you
doesn't mean that you get to
be,
that you get to wander off the
path and make things worse.
And maybe it doesn't matter how
terrible it is that what happens to you.
That's a tough call,
you know,
because you see people now and then in
life who they've really got it rough man,
like 50 bad things are happening to
them at the same time and you think,
oh,
it's no wonder if you are bitter and
resentful and hostile and be like,
yeah,
no wonder.
But then you meet people and social
needs and again talked about this in the
Gulag archipelago.
He said he met lots of
people in the not lot.
He met enough people to impress him in
the concentration camp system who didn't
allow their misfortunes to corrupt them.
And that's something man,
because maybe the only real
misfortune is to become corrupted.
That's a really useful thing to think.
You know,
maybe the rest of it,
maybe the rest of it is
trivial in comparison.
I know that's a rough thing because
you can be in very harsh circumstances,
but I do think there's something to that.